tensions rise at tonight's Henderson
city council meeting over the state of
the police department
we've got a big problem it's resulted in
a no-confidence vote
your response to this the very next day
was to say oh we fully support the chief
we fully have confidence in him
nobody reaches out and says hey guys
what's the problem
you don't do that or goes two ways and
no one knocked on mine do your job
unions do your job
this has been a failed experiment with
you
since you brought in Leticia Watson it's
not working it needs to get because
she's black and because he's black no
what's the failed Excel
that's disgusting
that exchange involving Henderson mayor
Deborah March after several people in
attendance brought up problems within
the police department earlier this month
two police unions voted no confidence in
current Henderson police chief that Rick
Andres a couple of minutes after that
exchange Chief Andres told the council
that he is willing to sit down with the
police unions to sort out the issues
mayor March added that the city has
prioritized Public Safety and invested
in its Police Department